now it's my pleasure to introduce ian
lee uh
ian is a phd student under my
supervision at the university of
waterloo
he's going to talk about restarts and
sat solvers
uh ian the floor is yours thank you ian
thank
uh thank you everyone for coming into
the talk uh
so the the work i'm going to present is
a joint work of
of uh myself and noah fleming mark
mignolet tony pitasi and
vijay ganesh so uh during previous talks
uh uh
from this program the restart problem
has been mentioned several times and
it's a quite big open problem in the
research upset
so before we go into the details of
restarts let's look at you know why do
we
care about the restart problem in the
first place so from the
empirical perspective right we simply
know solvers with restarts
outperform solvers without research like
an analogy is like
adding clause learning to a dpl or
sovereign right the gain is massive
and another reason is a restart is a
quite
natural uh heuristic
or choice to consider when you're
working with a search procedure right
the intuition is if your search
procedure uh
kind of gets unlucky and going to a bad
quote-unquote bad
part of the search phase you would like
the the procedure to restart and
try somewhere else and potentially you
can get lucky
and from a theoretical perspective right
i'm going to refer to this in famous
results again
so uh it's proved that cdcl with
non-deterministic branching and restarts
is p equivalent to general resolution
however
this theorem kind of relies on you know
having restart being one of this
assumption
uh and it's unclear if uh if you take
out restarts
uh the equivalent still holds and this
result is important because uh with this
result we can you know
go back and open our proof complexity
toolbox and then start lifting results
to
to uh two solvers
and another thing is if you are you have
if you happen to work on the restart
problem before
i think you agree with me that the
restore problem is super interesting to
work with so why not
uh so talking about like the history of
restart of it right
so restart have been studied extensively
in the
in the broad research area of certain
optimization problems
where the idea is to to use restart to
escape local minima or maxima
and research would first used
or adopted in a dpl setting right where
upon invocation
the solver basically erase the
assignment trail and start a search from
the new
and later research in cpcl servers are
a bit different right uh upon invocation
of restarts the software erases the
trail
but it also keeps some in other
information it has
learned or gained during the search for
instance
uh one of the restart doesn't uh erase
is the the learn class database and it
also preserves
activities in visits branching and it
also preserves
face saving values
but coming back to the questions right
like are restarts really useful
processors
and how do we justify it empirically and
how do we prove it theoretically
uh in this talk i'll focus on more on
the theoretical side
so uh there has been uh
two perspectives of this restart problem
right like empirical perspective and
theoretical perspective so on the
empirical side people have
proposed possible explanations of the
power
of research so probably the most famous
one is this
heavy tail explanation which applies to
some randomized version of dpl solvers
and the idea is it was observed that
different runs of randomized dpl servers
the solving type
of different runs of dpl server times
has a huge variance
so in other words
chances are if you just
run the solver multiple times one of the
run will give you a really
short uh short uh short proof or you can
find a satisfying assignment really
quickly
so if we if you let the software restart
the solver has can exploit this huge
variance in the solving time and
potentially get lucky
but this explanation doesn't really lift
to a cdcl
setting perfectly because there are a
variety of reasons
but i'll mention two reasons here first
reason is
uh the model being considered here is a
randomized model
well cdcl servers are usually uh
more complicated in the sense that for
example we are working with you know
locality-based
of solvers which means that
choice variable being branch on are not
completely like randomized
like like in this setting and another
reason is
perhaps the more important reason is
that cdc also have
close learning and more importantly
these closets are not
uh removed across restart boundary right
in the dpl setting once you restart
i'm literally starting the search from
scratch right i'm looking at the
original formula and then duration
but in the city of setting once you
restart you're essentially working with
a new formula
and another explanation is this restarts
compact assignment trail right
this is quite intuitive because uh
at some point your your assignment trail
is too long and then
it contains uh literals that may not
really contribute to the
the the conflict you are working on like
the software is working on
at the moment so chances are it's good
to restart and then you know only
the solver will naturally branch on the
variables that are more recent and more
local
and this hypothesis was later
verified by one of our paper which uh
exploits this uh observation and then
proposed a machine learning based
research policy
and on the theoretical side
it's a quite a common approach to model
uh solvers without restarting the proof
system
proof system and then by establishing
like uh the existence of you know a
candidate class that could potentially
separate out this
exponentially separate separate cells
there's proof system and general
resolution
one can prove whether restart can give
you exponential power
but however the final answer of
whether restarts really needed is is
still open
but the common consensus among community
is that cbcl servers without restarts
are weaker than than general general
resolution or the server with restarts
so as we were start working on this
problem for a while we started
we realized the restart problem is
actually quite subtle
and allowed me to explain that so if you
look into a
inside the set server and you unpack it
and look into each of the components
there is actually a collection of
components right so for example you have
variables
variable selection you have value
selection you have conflict analysis
you have background you have class
vision restarts
and possibly feel more like for example
how variables are propagated
due to like too much literal or
something else um
and the idea is that each of these
components can be implemented or
or there can be like different
heuristics you can choose to
put in bush components right for example
for variable selection function you can
say
my solver branch non-deterministically
which is a fair assumption
or i can assume my solver branch is
purely random right
or i can even weaken it to say the
solver has to branch
according to a predetermined static
ordering
and for conflict analysis you know we
can have first uip we can have decision
learning scheme we can have second uip
okay we can have 30 ipv right
so i guess the idea is to say by
choosing
a specific implementation of a of a
of a component in solver and by putting
all the components together
we end up with the what we call a
configuration of a set solver
right and as you can see there can be
many many configurations of cd cell
sensors
and this raises a very natural question
in the context of restarts right
that is is there does there exist a
configuration such that restart at
exponential power
while in the same time there exists some
other configuration where restart
doesn't add any power and
the answer turns out to be yes uh
we were able to show that uh we
in our set 2020 paper we are able to
establish four separation and two
equivalent equivalence theorems
between solvers with and without
restarts
and in this talk i'll briefly discuss
two of the more important results
separation results we got
in the paper so the first one is we
separated out
a drunk cdcl with and with without
essentially separated out trunks cpcl
with and without restart
uh this model is inspired by the drunk
dpl model by aleknoy chateau
and uh i guess the only modification is
that we are adding class learning to to
lift dpl to cdcl
and to uh just to talk about the model a
bit
uh by drawing cdcl we mean the solver
with backtracking
and non-deterministic variable selection
but random
value selection and class learning so on
a high level the solver
is smart enough to know what variables
to branch on
and it has the choice to do so but what
it doesn't have control is
what kind of polarity are assigned to
these uh
these variables and this is exactly the
property we exploit to
prove the separation so what we proved
that for
a class of satisfying formula which we
call a ladder formula
drunk cdcl without restarts takes
exponential time while strong
cdcl with restarts takes polynomial time
and this is with
high with high probability because we
are dealing with some random
model here and the second result is
uh based on what uh mark just presented
uh it's for a model of ctcl with visits
branching
so we can consider of
cdcl with visit with back jumping and
this is variable selection and
phase face saving value selection and we
proved that for
unsatisfied formula which is based on
the pitfall formula
mark just presented we show that cdcl
solvers with
visits without restarts takes
exponential time while
cdc with visits and restarts takes
polynomial time
again with high probability
uh before i go into the uh more of a
detail of this discussion i
want to just uh stay on the high level
and talk about you know
how is our approach differ from the
previous approach so
it's mainly different from true
perspective right
from previous approaches uh
sales offers are usually modeled as
proof systems right and then it's imp
we are implicitly dealing with
unsatisfiable formulas and then
talking about uh proof size lower bound
or upper bounds with them
and in our setting we are also
considering satisfiable homeowners
because uh
restart can have different impact you
know in in these two contacts and then
even though they are related we may end
up getting uh different insights
in in both domains and another
difference is
uh again when you're considering a
process proof system system right
you're implicitly assuming some
non-determinism
within the system right but in our
approach we are starting
studying a more fine grain of
uh configurations of accessories and
where we weaken certain heuristics from
being
non-deterministic to to some weaker
weaker version
so why do we consider a weakened
heuristic in the first place right
because again because uh the subtlety
we absorbed from uh for restarts
so there seems to be a very subtle
interplay between solver heuristics and
the power of three stars
the power of research seems to only
become more apparent
when certain heuristics are weaker than
non-deterministic
i'll now present uh kind of like a
high-level proof
methodology and as you can see i stole
this picture from
uh from mark i will explain uh
our lower bound upper bound uh argument
on a very high level
so just to describe this pitfall uh
right so i guess there's also a story
here so
we first as we were working on the
restart problem right we first developed
this lander formula which we showed
which we were trying to show the
separation in a satisfied setting
and then we just attended uh one of
mark's talk on this pit performance
and he realized there's something in
common right so we started collaborating
and then
it seems like we can generalize the the
the formulas we constructed in both
cases and then kind of
think about it on the on a high level in
the sense of this easy trap and hard
construction so
um the pit performers have three
components to it
the heart formula which we know are like
have a known lower bounds for resolution
and for trap and there's also a trap
part
which kind of tricks the solver in
focusing on the on
on the hard formula and then there's an
easy formula and in our case for
separating restarts
we are using a small backdoor for the
easy format
and more specifically we are using weak
backdrop in the solid survival case and
strong backdoor for the unsatisfiable
case
and just to remind remind everyone what
a spectrum
means so a weak factor is defined for
satisfiable formulas
it's just it's a set of verbs where
there exists assignment to the weak
vector variable and if you if you set
the variables accordingly
the remaining formula becomes trivial to
solve so in other words if you can
somehow argue a solver can
assign these variables correctly then
you can easily find a satisfying
assignment
and a strong backdoor is defined for
unsatisfiable unsatisfiable formulas
where definition is under every
assignment to the backdoor a strong
background variables
the underlying formula becomes easy to
solve so in other words if you keep
co querying on the strong background
variables you can prove the form
uh and you have a small strong backdoor
you can prove the formula easy
so the lower bound argument for our
research operations kind of works like
this
you want to argue without restarts with
high probability the solver will fall
into the trap
and needs to refill the heart formula
before escaping and this is similar to
what uh
mark was saying and in the upper bound
setting essentially want to say the
solver
with restarts can exploit the small
backdoor
and for uh for strong factories
about finding the vector variable to
start with and then
and to branch off and for the weak
background setting
it's about finding the desired
assignment to the weak backdoor
variables such as remaining formula is
easy to solve
and just to go into a little bit of more
detail into this
these two results so for the drunk cdcl
separation we are considering
backtracking which undo the most recent
decision level upon learning conflict
and non-deterministic variable selection
and randomized value selection
and the latter formula is a satisfiable
satisfiable formula which contains a
login size weak backdoor
and all but one assignment to the weak
factor variables
implies getting tracked which in our
case we
we make the formula implies satan and
in the norway star case it's kind of
hard since we're um
since the drunk solver doesn't have a
you know it doesn't get to choose what
values are assigned to the variables
so it's very likely that even if the
server focuses on the
weak backdoor variables it it won't be
able to assign them to the desired
assignment
right so the argument will say uh
without restarts
it's hard to uh branch on assign the
variables
to their desired polarity and with high
probability
and thus implies a hard formula result
and for restarts we would like to argue
the solver can keep querying the
backdoor variables
until they assign them correctly and if
they're not assigned correctly
just simply restart and because the
solver has non-deterministic variable
selection it can just keep branching on
these spectral variables
until finds the desired assignment
and for the visit results
uh we are considering a model with back
jumping which is you know
the solar erases all uh
a literals on the assignment trail that
has that that's from a
higher decision level than the second
highest decision level in the learning
clause
and we have our business variable
selection
uh except we have a random type breaking
mechanism
and we also consider a version of
restarts that resets activities
and we have a face saving value
selection which basically
assigns the assigns a variable according
to
what polarity it was assigned last time
and
if a variable was never assigned we
simply assign it false to begin with
so the pitfall formula is an unset
unsatisfiable formula
which contains a constant size strong
vector
and with no restarts we want to argue
with high probability the first conflict
will bump activities of variables in the
heart formula
and this is exactly what mark was
showing earlier
and but with restarts we can restart
use restart to reset activities because
we have the
uh condition that whenever you're
restarting reset
activities of all uh variables and
additionally with this run random type
breaking
we can use these two uh properties to
kind of keep restarting and trying to
find
uh find the the strong background
variables to branch out
and we also have uh four other uh
two other equivalence results and two
other separation results on other like
configurations of cities of assessors uh
one of them being you know like we're
considering a really weak version of
static
static city sales solvers and some
non-deterministic dpll settings
and we also have a version of drunk dpll
and
i have a also have a separation result
on this weak decision learning scheme
this was a private conversation with
robert robert
and just to stay some key insights and
takeaways from this work credit
so there are three uh mainly three folds
the first point is
the the power of restart is quite subtle
and then
the power of restart may only become
more apparent when certain heuristics
are weaker than non-deterministic
and we also consider satisfied with both
satisfiable and unsatisfied performers
and the last one is this this pitfall
a framework where we can we can embed an
easy part of the formula and then embed
a heart formula
and then use a trap mechanism to connect
the two to uh
to to to construct formulas that are
suitable for separation results
and just some open questions uh of
course the the
mo the big question still remains
whether uh cdcl solvers without research
is pure
equivalent to general resolution still
remains open
and another question i would like to
bring up is this uh
is the difference between backtracking
and back jumping right so
backtracking if a server only backtracks
then
it's clearly a solver without restores
but back jumping are sometimes referred
to as a mini restart right but it is
never really formally
studied so the idea is even if you can
have a super long assignment trail
to start with and then you're somehow
like having a
heart formula embedded at the end of
this assignment trail
it's still possible to learn conflict
that involves you know
some uh very few literals from the top
of the salmon trail
and by back jumping you you have options
to you know back jump all the way up
uh to somewhere near the root of your
trade
so this is a quite powerful thing you
can do right
but this is still not as powerful as it
restarts because
you can never back jump the first uh
literally
uh your branched out unless you prove
the whole formula is unsatisfied
right so i think under like formalizing
and understanding the difference between
backtracking
and back jumping in the middle and
restarts can be a quite productive
direction to think about
and this concludes my talk thank you
very much
thank you ian for a fantastic talk thank
you so much
questions please
okay um so uh i had one question
ian about um
your right thoughts about use of
restarts
uh from a proof size versus proof search
perspective
do you have any ideas there or initial
thoughts
right so uh it's tricky like what you
are really comparing with right
uh so like if you want to think about
restart from an automatability point of
view right
are you comparing like are you assuming
a formula has a short restart
proof or like without assumptions it's
similar to what mark
showed like mark showed essentially an
automatability separation right
in his result for visas
i think what makes sense is maybe we can
consider different versions
of uh restart policies like maybe one
you require like
a fixed interval and some other density
by then you can like talk about
automatability right
like yeah okay
any additional questions
uh yep sam go ahead please yeah it was
one if you could say
a few words about the equivalence result
you stated
first i think it was for static cdcl uh
right
so what about the definitions yeah yeah
so the model we're considering is quite
uh it's very
very constrained from some perspective
right so by static what we
mean is uh so first of all the server
has back dumping
and it's using static variable selection
and static value selection right
this is kind of like uh before you even
run the solver you cannot predetermine
the ordering of the variables right
and each time you want to brand a
variable you just branch according to
this
other right it's a very fixed order so
the idea is
uh if you have a solver solver without
restart
sorry with the software sorry
using the solver with restart even if
you restart you still have to kind of
follow this
fixed ordering right and then you are
basically reconstructing the trail
to the point where uh before you you
call the restart
on a high level so yeah so yeah
does that answer the question or yeah
yes thank you
thank you all right
thank you all the speakers for a
fantastic talk thank you paul
mark noah and ian and
we'll meet tomorrow i guess same time
thank you everybody bye-bye